Ray Stevenson achieved a unique
distinction in the Star Wars Universe by
portraying two different characters if
car Saxon could see
you I know right yeah the intervoiced
gar Saxon and the animated shows Star
Wars the Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels
while also playing balance skull in the
live action Ahsoka series the latter
sees Stevenson living every Fan's
biggest dream of wielding a lightsaber
and going toe-to-toe with Rosario
Dawson's Ahsoka Tano Stevenson
recognized the magnitude and importance
of stepping into the below Star Wars
franchise speaking to Entertainment
Weekly he revealed the intense
preparation and dedication that went
into his portrayal of Balin while
praising the environments and hard work
that his collaborators put into making
the Disney plus series come to life on a
personal level Stevenson couldn't help
but get caught up in the moments when he
picked up a lightsaber for the first
time he confided to Entertainment Weekly
I must admit the first time you turn a
lightsaber on you make the noise and
then you're like oh I'm so sorry
everybody does that but you just can't
help it